good morning believe nation welcome to
another edition of the Evan Carmichael
show i'm your host Evan Carmichael now
I'm a little bit sick today so if you
hear the occasional sniffle or cough I
apologize in advance but I am excited to
be with you here today this show is all
about helping you grow your business is
helping you reach your goals is helping
you break through the obstacles that are
in front of you and building the company
of your dreams on the episode today
we're going to talk about how to develop
a skill when to quit your job I'm going
to have a special guest Dave Curlin
who's a sales guru who's going to share
his wisdom and how to stop being afraid
of imperfection all right so I recent
got asked a question on Twitter by hakan
Stein KRG who asked me how do you
develop a skill and the easy answer to
this is you practice right whatever
skill you want to develop whether it's
in business or personal skill the more
you practiced more likely going to get
better right if you want to improve your
copywriting you gotta practice if you
want to be a radio show host you got to
practice if you want to learn French or
Spanish or how to ride a bike you gotta
practice so that's a simple answer but
to add a layer on top of that to help
speed up that skill development the best
way to do it the most effective way to
do it is the model success and that's
where you find someone who has already
achieved that skill a mastery level a
level that you want to get to and model
what work for them and apply it to you
and that can be either in the form of a
personal mentor somebody that you're
meeting face to face and giving you
advice or could just be the form of
researching and finding somebody who has
gone out and done it and read their
biography and watch their videos and
read newspaper interviews with them
learn how they did it because practicing
is great but you have to make sure
you're practicing the right things and
if you could spend tons of time
practicing practicing practicing but
it's not on the right things your
development will get will be a lot
slower than if you're practicing the
right things so a quick example you guys
listen on this radio show when I first
started the show I I had been on radio
before but I never had my own show I've
been a guest and other people shows and
so my agent put me in touch with a media
coach
and we trained and we practicing she
drilled me and we did mock shows before
that went and did my first one and then
after every episode that I had we
analyzed the tape we went over
everything and she gave me
recommendations for what to improve and
she gave me more tests and drills and
that really sped up my development
because I was putting in the work I was
willing to practice but she told me the
right things practice now you may be
thinking well you know I don't have
enough money to hire a coach to help me
or I don't have anybody in my network
who's done what I want to do and that's
okay don't give up don't let that be
your excuse for not trying and not
moving forward on your goal what you can
do is still model success by reading the
stories of people who've already done
what you want to do and that's what
literally saved my business there was a
story about Bill Gates and how he
started his software company right not
how he makes an extra million now but
how he went from zero to one and when I
was struggling with my business which
was also software in making three
hundred dollars a month that's the story
that that saved me I realized that he
formed partnerships with other companies
and applied that strategy to my business
and I started to grow and so yes you
have to put in the work and yes you have
to keep you know putting in those hours
and working hard and practicing and
practicing and practicing to develop
your skill but to be really effective at
it you have to make sure you're
practicing the right things and that
you're applying your strategies by being
coached by somebody or by mullen success
of somebody that you look up to and the
bigger that person is the more
established they are the more of a truck
work but they have the easier it is to
find their stories and apply their
strategies to help you develop whatever
skill that you're trying to learn all
right I want to get to the calls that's
the fun part for me on this show I have
who do I have I have Regina on the line
Regina where are you from and how can I
help i am from marcus thorough tennessee
and i'm currently in the process of
writing a book and i'm suffering from
fair paralysis so how do you overcome
that so what what what do you what are
you afraid of what are you afraid of
writing afraid of releasing it what do
you what's holding you back I think what
I think remain hits the content I'm
afraid that maybe I don't
I've just figured out that that's what's
keeping me from writing like I should be
doing every day is maybe that there's
audience thousand other books with the
content that I'm going to be putting
into mind and let's try I guess I'm
scared you know that I'm going to be
it's not gonna it's gonna be a flop
what's the topic of the book it's a
business survival tips for small bars
I'm too small bars and I've gone through
so many obstacles in my seven years and
through these obstacles I've learned
many many things that I've met other
business owners that don't or have never
you know challenged or I had to happen
to them and they're like me and I always
try to know this before it happened to
me which is what inspired me to write a
book of all of my challenges that I've
had to overcome over the seven years and
running a small roadside bar got it I
love it and I recommend two things for
you that I think will help you Regina
the first is adding yourself to the book
and telling your story and telling the
success you've had with the two bars and
the failures because if you're just
giving just general tips then that's
what everybody else is doing and so the
way you stand out is by making it more
Regina right so telling your story
sharing your wisdom sharing exactly what
happened to you that's what makes people
connect to you a lot more than just
reading those general tips so anybody
can can be a bar expert but not
everybody can be Regina so you've got to
make the book as much Regina as possible
and applying your wisdom and your
stories to each of the tips that you're
providing so that's how you stand out
that's one way to stand out and make it
different from everybody else because if
you have you know you know Jon Taffer
right he's maybe the Guru of you know of
making over bars I was on his chill bar
rescue team came to mate over my bar so
I know John to ever really well great I
mean and he has his style right he has
his way of doing things and he has his
stories and his methodology and a lot of
people are tuned to that and they love
it and they apply it but others may not
or they may need to hear it in a
different
in a different voice in different
examples and different stories and
that's where you can come in okay so
adding Regina to every tip that you're
giving so not just the strategy but
adding your personal touch each thing
the other thing that will help
especially for these big projects you
know like it takes a long time to write
a book and it's easy to get discouraged
along that process think about the
people that you've helped but think
about the other bar owners and the other
entrepreneurs that that you have helped
with your advice and and you realize man
I really I really helped that person
really maybe even save help save that
person's bar I call those the little why
it's like the those individual people
that you help on an ongoing basis can
give you the the extra encouragement and
motivation to realize that hey what I'm
doing is important right like it
actually helps people I'm providing
value to the world and by me putting all
my thoughts down into this book it's
going to be able to reach a lot more
people and helped a lot more people
right I'm currently working with some
small business owners with their
business and you know that Betty is
helping me that's helping me to say you
know that okay maybe you know my my
knowledge is good again because when I
first started this project I was so gung
ho and I was just I was going to get in
there and I was going to have it done in
three months and here it is eight months
later and I'm still sitting there
staring at my chapters I've got this
nice real big skeleton made out all I
gotta do is put the meat on the bones
and it's just when i get there it's like
you know I stopped I found other things
I'm prioritizing the wrong things in my
life and I'm not getting to my writing
and that's where that we've learned or
I've learned that that's my fear
paralysis happening what I would try
doing is if you know you have a writing
day so like tuesdays and thursdays are
your writing days just use as an example
i would try the first thing in the
morning on those days line up a call
with a small business owner that you're
helping have a half-hour called with
them to give them advice and wisdom and
and help them along along their journey
and you'll get off of that call feeling
so great about yourself and
your value and the wisdom that you're
providing that carry that through then
into the rest of your writing day so we
have you know like nine to five writing
have a 830 call 29 just to get you going
get that motivation get that spark get
that energy and then carry that through
to the rest of your day and know that
you're providing value to the
entrepreneurs who event you read this
book wonderful well I thank you so much
for your advice and I am going to apply
that no problem what's the name of your
book so I can look for when it comes out
it's going to be killed our special
recipes are made in chatt survival
techniques of a roadside bar in
Tennessee it is um empty bottle bar and
grill which was on an episode of bar
rescue but i think it was season three
it was called empty bottles full cans
and so that's our motto our special
recipes are made in cash so thanks for
Gina I've got to let you go but thank
you so much for calling in and good luck
with the book and for everybody
listening have those little wise have
those things that motivate you that that
reminded of what you're doing is
providing value that is helpful and
carry that through to the rest of your
day to give you that energy to go
forward and continue creating awesome
work to help the next question I had was
from ignace who wrote in to say that he
has his job and he loves his co-workers
but nothing to complain about but he
hates going to work there every day
because all eight hours he's there he's
thinking about his own business and is
wondering is it time to quit your job so
there's three things you want to think
about when you're going to quit your job
okay number one have a job where you're
learning you don't want to jump just for
a paycheck you want a job where you're
going to learn about your industry so I
try to go work for a company that's in
your industry that's a smallish company
something that you aspire to be and you
can get close to the entrepreneur
founder and you can learn as much as
possible and make the mistakes that way
you're getting paid to make mistakes
you're getting paid to learn about the
industry and you're going there for more
than just a paycheck okay if you're
having a job you want to make sure using
it to learn so that's number one make
sure the job you're in you're learning
from it
number two is start part-time not your
company now right started on the evening
started in weekends you got to allow
time for momentum to grow so don't wait
until you're going to quit your job and
then go full time on your business start
it up part time right now that's the
best time to get going and number three
you quit when you can support yourself
right you quit when you're making enough
money from your business to be able to
support yourself and your livelihood and
and that doesn't mean you're making a
rich okay you're not off buying Tesla's
for yourself from your business but
you're able to pay your rent you're able
to pay your mortgage you're able to put
food on the table you know the
electricity company is not going to come
in and shut you off that's when you quit
at your job okay because you want to
make sure too many others make that
mistake they go all in and then they
quickly run out of savings they only
have you know three months of savings
and it doesn't work out they had to go
back and get a job and I don't want that
to be you so number one have a job where
you're learning number to start part
time and number three quit when you can
support yourself I wanna get to the
calls again I have Michelle on the line
Michelle where are you from and how can
I help i I'm from Randolph New Jersey
and I am in the process of starting at
my own daycare I have a site we're going
through the licensing procedures of the
building is up to code my question is
what is the most cost efficient way for
me to advertise without breaking the
bank considering right now everything is
just laying out money you know there's
obviously nothing coming in at the
moment right and when you're going to be
up and running the goal is to be up and
running for july first so I mean it's
around the corner cool so the two things
I would look at one is making alliances
you know who is already connected to
these groups of young parents and how
can you connect with them to do
co-marketing right who already has the
audience that you're going after and how
can you help each other right so if you
can think of other businesses that
aren't daycares that are also selling to
new parents or young parents and you
know maybe you could have their flyers
in your store or in your your your day
care and in return there helping market
you to their
audience but there's some people that
come to mind yeah there are a few
businesses absolutely and and actually
because I'm starting to put together my
staff you know they have young children
and you know that's the draw to working
in the field so you know I've even told
the staff that I'm in the process of
trying to hire and train and prepare you
know word of mouth yeah so I've been
looking at our their local you know mom
and pop baby shop stores right there
selling strollers and selling you know
bottles and all the stuff think about
where where the parents have to buy for
their kids before they come to you right
all the things that a parent has to buy
those stores or potential partners for
you because then they're going to come
to you next right so before I have my
kid I'm going to go and buy a stroller
and by the by the you know swaddles and
by the crib and all that and then and
then after the baby's born I'm going to
be interested in daycare services so
those kinds of stores would be great
potential promotional partners for you
and I mean the phila date care how many
how many people can you fit how many
kids can you fit in your day care we are
licensed or only 50 it's a small center
right so I mean 50 is not a lot in
comparison to how many people are coming
in the foot traffic to those stores fine
various baby toys and equipment so i
would i would make a concerted effort to
introduce myself to all of those stores
that are selling to the parents have
them know who you are and look it look
for a way to market with each other and
you know you could have their
information in your day care and they
could market you in their store the
other thing i try to do is try to make a
splash in the local media i would get in
touch with all the reporters all the
even bloggers that are local anybody
even on twitter or youtube that is local
to where you are that covers these
issues and introduce yourself and talk
about what's you know what you believe
in what's different about your daycare
right not just you're just not just
another day care out there what's so
different about Michelle's awesome day
care right your philosophy right
and have you be a potential you know
expert to talk about whatever issues are
permanent or prevalence are in the day
care industry right now you could have a
column in a local newspaper you could be
a guest on somebody's YouTube channel
make that list and then be the expert so
what is what's so different about
Michelle's daycare compared to the other
ones what's different is the fact that
we're trying to make it more of a family
environment and meeting the needs of
every single child the one reason that
drew me to want to even start it was so
many of my friends are saying oh my
child got kicked out of daycare because
they bit three times and they have this
rule and I'm like well that's a crazy
rule to kick a child out of daycare you
know and you know just listening to my
friends who have young children too and
it's like you know some of these
daycares they charge crazy money and
they have these crazy rules and they
impose things that you know biting is is
a normal process developmental process
and that's actually what you're going to
want to do this got it so that's very
cool and that could definitely be a
story though that could be multiple
stories right you could have a story
about what it means to have a family
environment in the daycare you can have
a story about ridiculous rules that
daycares have you could have a story
about how biting is a normal part of a
child's development and people need to
understand that those could all be
different angles and different stories
that the media would be interested in
that a mommy youtuber might be
interested in mommy bloggers might be
interested in especially if they are
aligned with the same feelings as you
are right if you have a mommy blogger
who feels the exact same way that
fighting is normal and these rules are
ridiculous they're gonna love you right
and they're gonna want to feature you
and share your daycare and honestly to
get 50 people it's not it's not a huge
number right you're not trying to get
you know a thousand new students coming
in or so look at making partnership and
look at get into the media both of them
are totally free strategies doesn't cost
you anything pretty high leverage and I
think will help you grow your business
thank you so much I appreciate the help
no problem Michelle good luck if ever
listen in and you don't have to go out
and spend lots of money to market your
business I know it's stressful and it's
a lot of money that may go out you know
you certainly daycares a lot of expenses
that go out right at the start to set up
your location and the last I'm going to
do is start spending tons and tons of
money promoting it so by using the media
by using the social media and bloggers
and connecting to youtubers in your
community and then by forming alliances
you'll have a much higher degree of
success in marketing your business and
being able to to grow it to the next
level without having to spend tons and
tons and tons of money welcome back to
the oven Carmichael show I believe in
entrepreneurs and I'm really excited
today to have a special guest on with me
Dave curling a buddy of mine he's a
sales guru he's written a number of
books on the topic he's also a baseball
fan which is important we like different
teams but I'll still have him on the
show Dave how are you doing I'm doing
great Evan great to be on the show again
my Blue Jays are in the tank so I don't
want to talk about baseball right now
yeah my Red Sox are doing even worse so
I think we're tied with the Blue Jays
for last place so not a great subject
right now all right well I believe we're
going to come out of it I'm not so
optimistic on my end let's talk about
something that time we can help people
with I think it change the tone is
something more optimistic let's talk
about selling value why do people make
such a big deal about selling value well
it's become more important recently
because so many companies and so many
products are getting commoditized and
buyers are approaching products from a
price perspective and wanting the best
price in the lowest price and companies
can't stay in business if they're giving
their stuff away and with all this
pressure on price margins are getting
smaller profits are getting smaller it's
putting more pressure on companies to do
even more volume than before salespeople
are having trouble and struggling to do
that additional volume so instead it's
important that companies learn to
differentiate by selling value and
selling console
natively and doing things that will
support value selling so so this is a
value proposition is that what we use
the cell value well you know it's
interesting the value proposition came
into vogue maybe back in the 80s when it
became fashionable to construct the
company value proposition which was
really a piece of marketing brilliant
marketing the unique value proposition
but soon every company had a value
proposition and they all founded the
thing so in the late 90s we started to
see the value add so in addition to the
value proposition the value-add was the
thing that company would do over and
above what someone was paying for but by
the 2000s everybody had a value add so
in each of these iterations we get to a
point where everybody was the same again
and it allowed pires to commoditize
companies and products so today there's
still a value proposition companies
still have a unique value proposition
and they're still doing a value add but
the big differentiator today is the
salesperson and they must differentiate
by not adding value and not talking
about that value but by actually being
the value and that's important because
unlike even five or ten years ago today
anything that a prospect our customer or
a fire needs to know they can find on
the internet so sales people used to be
a source of knowledge and a source of
pricing and a product expert people
don't need that anymore from sales
people so salespeople have to bring
something more valuable to the table
then knowledge about their own
they have to bring industry knowledge
application knowledge and most
importantly they've got to ask the tough
questions that cause prospects to
rethink their strategies and rethink
their way of doing things and perhaps
change their approach and and they're
thinking behind why they might have
needed a product or a service in the
first place so for the entrepreneurs and
sales people listening to the show who
may be trying to do things the old way
and maybe just you know trying to pound
the phones and it's not working as well
as it used to is there is there a
checklist that you go through a
recommended you know steps or is there
an example you can share with someone
doing it right that they can use as a
template just trying to get you know how
do i how do I be that person that is
value instead of just trying to have a
value proposition sure so let's let's
walk it through but we'll walk it
through backwards instead of forwards so
backwards would be the point where we
were finally talking about money and the
mistakes that those sales people you're
talking about are making is if they give
a prospect the slightest hope that they
can have the best price the lowest price
need a price discount the price
negotiate the price all the things that
salespeople do is a crutch to get the
business then they're they're moving
away from selling value and they're
moving toward selling on price and the
minute the conversation moves away from
value and toward price then it is about
price and value goes away it's lost and
now we're commoditized and the only
differentiator will ultimately be the
price so instead they must know that
they can't make exceptions they can
allude to a better price this is the
price and to support that price a couple
things need to happen
we get to money the first is that the
salesperson must uncover a compelling
reason as to why this prospect or this
company would want to move their
business to us you know they're doing
business with somebody else why would
they leave why would they give that up
why would they change what's wrong what
isn't good enough what once one of the
Hang Ups what's one of the frustrations
and how is that impacting them and how
is that affecting their life and how's
that affecting profits and is it costing
anything so can we identify a compelling
reason why they move their business to
us can we uncover the consequences of
whatever problems are going on and can
we quantify those consequences so that's
being a consultative customer focused
approach to selling where instead of
talking about us and what we sell we're
talking about them and what's going on
and how that impacts them if we've
uncovered a compelling reason and a
consequence and been able to quantify it
the second thing we have to do is
differentiate ourselves so that
conversation will help to differentiate
ourselves but continuing to have a
conversation where we're asking lots of
questions we're asking lots of good
questions tough questions and even
having the conversation that nobody's
ever had with them before where we can
push back and challenge their thinking
that's how we differentiate we don't
differentiate with features benefits
anymore we don't differentiate by having
a better price anymore we differentiate
by having a valuable conversation about
them and what's going on and uncovering
reasons why we might be able to help and
then and then being able to ask whether
they'll not whether if we had a
competitive price they'd consider
but I said if they're willing to spend a
little bit more to do business with us
in order to solve this problem that's
affecting them this way and costing them
this much money right so we're
introducing costs in the context of the
quantification of their problem right so
it sounds like you know you gotta really
understand your product and service
really understand how it can help them
and actually care about them right and
actually try to have a conversation to
figure out what's best for them
understand their needs and kind of craft
it around that and showing that care
really helps you stand out you bring out
a great point there because as we're
asking these questions and having this
conversation we are showing that we are
listening which is different from what
most salespeople do we're showing that
we care about them and their company and
their plight which is different from
what most salespeople do we're making it
about them which is different from what
most salespeople do and through this
conversation we're demonstrating our
expertise not because we're talking
about what we know because we're asking
the right questions and that helped
helps us establish credibility so we
differentiate ourselves in that way too
and along the way because of this great
conversation we're building a
relationship and we may end up at the
end of this conversation with a better
relationship than anybody else has with
them right I love it Dave for people who
are listening in and they want to learn
more where can they learn about you oh
all they have to do is Google Dave
Carlin k you are l am and I'm sure they
can find me very easily doing that they
could also email me it's D Curlin at
Curlin associates com or they can visit
my blog which is o.m.g like oh my god
except it stands for objective
management group hub OMG hub hu be calm
awesome thank you so much for joining
Dave look forward to talk to you soon
great being on with you again Evan
looking forward to the next one
welcome back to the oven carmichael
show-- i believe in entrepreneurs I risa
got asked a question by one of my
YouTube followers Cindy who wrote in to
say how can I give it all to my dreams
how can something afraid of imperfection
this is really important because as
entrepreneurs you tend to have really
great taste right you know what's good
you know what's not good you've acquired
this taste over years and years and
years but your skills your abilities
aren't quite matching up to your taste
yet the stuff that you create isn't
amazing it isn't of that same caliber
and so everything you create you think
sucks you think has to be better think
has to be perfect and that holds you
back from continuing on what you have to
understand is everything you learn is
just like a skill and it gets better
with practice and you have to practice
and practice and practice and don't
compare yourself to where you want to be
yet compare yourself to what you did
last time and slowly you'll close that
gap so you're close the gap between what
you know is really good and what you can
create and the challenge is so much
often is riding on that I'm having that
perfect product that perfect creation
that if it doesn't work out you feel
like you've lost everything right you
lose all meaning because you've lost
your hope you've lost that dream project
and so you'd rather do nothing then try
because you know what you're going to
try is going to not be great and so
understand that there's that gap
understand that you have really high
tastes and really high expectations of
yourself but you don't have the skills
and abilities yet and you can close that
gap and you will close that gap but only
through consistency and following
through and practicing so it's okay to
suck at the start you'll suck at
anything at the start and every time you
continue moving forward you'll get
better and better and better I have time
for one last caller I have Tim on the
line Tim where are you from and how can
I help I'm from Colorado Springs
Colorado and right the question I the
question I have is on I've started doing
corporate speaking gigs I translate my
career as a firefighter and leadership
and teamwork and firefighting to the
corporate environment and kind of
compare and contrast those two things
and so the question I have is how do i
how do I set pricing you know I've had
people willing to pay 1500 to do it and
I just I've read stuff that says you got
to be at least 2,500 and I don't I don't
know really how to price it so one it'll
it's a great question and this is a
classic kind of supplied the main issue
if you have tons of space open and no
gigs than that $1,500 cake looks pretty
good if you're kind of full up on those
then you can start to you know give you
know lose deals because you don't care
because you have you know more than
enough it'll often depend on the client
which is what I found in the speaking
that I do some clients you don't have a
very minimal budget and some clients
will have a much larger budget you know
for most of my speaking gigs it's ten
thousand dollars plus travel and
accommodations and all of that stuff but
not everybody can afford that and so if
you're dealing with an organization
that's smaller which I'll often have you
know a lot of entrepreneurs they don't
have a lot of money so I might take a
speaking gig that's for less money or
for free because I really believe in
what they're doing and because my
schedule permits it so what I try to do
is when I get on a call with somebody I
always asked what their budget is I
always try to have them give me a little
bit of information some clues and I'll
start at a high number and see what
their reaction is I'll start at my ten
thousand dollars which is my preferred
rate and then some people are like oh
that's way too high I can't kind of come
in or close to that I was thinking more
like 1500 right and then just thinking
okay does that fit you know do I like
this organization this is going to be
good for my brand do I want to help
these people do I have it in my schedule
the availability to do it or not and
over time as you get better as you build
a reputation you can charge more and
more and more and more and more you know
I my $10,000 that's nowhere near the top
of the spectrum at last question on that
who do you approach in the in the core I
mean you go out and sell yourself or do
you wait for people to come to you
because if I'm at the point where I got
to go out and make my own contacts
and I'm just wondering who's the best
person to approach in an organization
for the ask honestly the best results
I've had or through youtube I put my
stuff on YouTube I posed two videos a
day now you may not be able to do two
videos a day and that's cool but you
know people want to see your if you're a
speaker YouTube is a great place to be
because it's a very visual medium right
they want to see you speaking whether
it's in front of an audience or just you
at your home or at the fire hall or
wherever because there's a lot of
corporate people who are on YouTube or
even on google searching for those
topics right so you can you could do it
you could do a session on leadership
lessons from the fire hall as an example
just pulling something out you people in
corporate will be looking for leadership
lessons you know and your video will pop
up and if it's good then they're gonna
see what else is on your channel say why
I really like this Tim guy he's got a
really unique gangoh creative message
they're gonna reach out to you and want
to do some kind of deal whether that's a
speaking opportunity whether it's making
a video for their channel whether it's
you know doing joining their sales calls
with their team and motivating them
whatever it is I have an agent I have I
work with speaking houses I find the
best result honestly have come just
threw my youtube channel thank you look
I have a tail so I need to expand what I
do on the channel yeah I put at least
one video a week on the channel I don't
know what you're doing right now but at
least one a week saying if you're
getting questions from corporate if you
see like common questions you get asked
at those engagements I would turn those
into individual videos the think about
the last speaking of you did and the
questions you got from the audience you
had ten questions turn it to those in
the ten separate you know three to five
minute videos on YouTube or vector one
regular cool all right good luck yeah
one for everybody listening in I get
yourself out on social media it's so
easy to use its so free it's where
everybody's attention is going these
days and when somebody is doing a search
for whatever your product or service is
you want to be able to show up
especially if you're in a visual medium
right you're talking about being a
speaker that's such a visual medium you
can't you can't do justice
how good a speaker you are by writing an
article right because the whole point of
it is it's visual they want to see you
on stage doing your thing and so
producing regular content on social
media is a fantastic way to get exposure
to get people to learn about you to grow
your business to make partnerships you
get speaking gigs to get corporate gigs
everybody get on YouTube one video per
week to grow all right it's been another
amazing show thank you guys so much for
tuning in thank you again to my
producers Daniela and Josh you guys rock
and for we're going to listen and
continue to believe and I will see you
soon